entschuldigung kommen sie von ihr ich ja
ja das ist gut dann können sie mir
vielleicht helfen ich sorge die st
jakobus kirche sankt jakobus kirche ja
ja nein ja leider nicht helfen also hier
steht die st jakobus kirche ist ein
imbiss sand gehaltenes gotteshaus mit
rot verbauten das ziel
über dem hauptportal befindet sich ein
kleines rundes fenster auch ochsenauge
genannt gesäumt von mehreren länglichen
rundbogenfenstern in guitar glasoptik
das ist ein sehr schöner bautzen sein
aber ich wohne seit 60 jahren praktisch
das gibt es bei uns nicht die
besonderheit die st jakobus kirche wurde
ohne kirchturm bauen
schade dann kann man da wohl nichts
machen wie blöd dass die das in so einen
reiseführer überhaupt reinschreiben
st jakobus kirche mit einem ochsenauge
über die portal- und ohne kirche
er wird doch nicht unsere jakobskirche
[Applaus]